[Music]
an apple a day keeps the doctor away
home is where the heart is
[Music]
a constant guest is never welcome
[Music]
a fool and his money are soon parted
[Music]
greater the danger the greater the honor
[Music]
take no notice of the stupid things
people say
when one is hungry everything tastes
good
hunger is good seasoning
look after the pennies and the pounds
will look after themselves
whom the gods love dies young
never spend your money before you have
it
as soon as one goes out the window
another one comes in the door
every dog has its day
[Music]
a good payer will not object to leaving
a deposit
[Music]
two in distress make sorrow less
[Music]
at the game's end we shall see who gains
[Music]
it never rains it pours
we must live by the living not by the
dead
half a loaf is better than no bread
[Music]
of all pains the greatest pain is to
love but love in vain
old friends old wine and old gold are
the best
[Music]
let bygones be bygones
to each his own god is watching over
everyone
each person knows where problems lie
a few germs never hurt anyone
when good cheer is lacking our friends
will be packing
appetite comes with eating
[Music]
patients time and money accommodate all
things
little strokes fell great oaks
a change is as good as a rest
[Music]
to air is human to forgive divine
never give advice unasked
a soft answer turneth away wrath
when drums beat laws are silent
[Music]
do what is right come what may
i don't care what people say as long as
i get what i want
a miss is as good as a mile
we're all a little crazy in one way or
another
[Music]
make the best of a bad bargain
all of us have been fools once in our
lives
you can judge a man by the company he
keeps
[Music]
birth is important but breeding is more
important
god sends cold after clothes
[Music]
there's no smoke without fire
poverty breeds discontent
love will find a way
married people need a home of their own
[Music]
money goes where money is
nothing succeeds like success
it's no crime to steal from a thief
[Music]
mischief comes by the pound and goes by
the ounce
[Music]
the greatest hate springs from the
greatest love
imitation is the sincerest form of
flattery
actions speak louder than words
dead men have no friends
[Music]
a faint heart never won a fair lady
[Music]
he that would have the fruit must climb
the tree
if at first you don't succeed try again
the early bird catches the worm
if you don't have what it takes you
won't get on in the world
[Music]
no bees no honey
no work no money no mill no meal
sometimes the remedy is worse than a
disease
[Music]
one can never know too much
we are all equal in the eyes of god
time heals all wounds
their small choice in rotten apples
[Music]
many hands make light work
[Music]
the shoemaker's son always goes barefoot
[Music]
any port in a storm
more than enough is too much
a friend in need is a friend indeed
things have changed time doesn't stand
still
he who excuses himself accuses himself
the grass always looks greener on the
other side of the fence
[Music]
what can't be cured must be endured
[Music]
there are plenty more fish in the sea
the walls have ears
[Music]
the devil looks after himself
[Music]
a rolling stone gathers no moss
[Music]
one good four wit is worth two
afterwards
[Music]
abundance of things engenders
disdainfulness
absence makes the heart grow fonder
anger is a brief madness
[Music]
a woman's place is in the home
[Music]
necessity is the mother of invention
if you talk too much you're likely to
give yourself away
[Music]
discretion is the better part of courage
[Music]
laughter is the best medicine
[Music]
health is better than wealth
if a man sleeps with two women they will
soon find out that neither of them
belongs to him
if you go away you can't expect people
to keep your place for you
strike while the iron is hot
[Music]
things happen when we least expect them
[Music]
he who is born to be hanged shall never
be drowned
[Music]